time now for our T-Mobile Coast to Coast
coverage
Clark's favorite color Celtics here on
Monday
Here Comes Derrick Rose fish foul on his
face
Tim's room acquiescing to the crowd what
is going on here
proud and a frenzy
everybody's on their feet cheering
foreign
we've seen the quotes from his teammates
he has been the perfect teammate helping
a lot of the young Nicks
throughout the season and practice
for road trips on the bench during games
and now he gets an opportunity on the
court and I wanted a buyouts and he
still wanted to stay with the team
[Applause]
the former League MVP it's using the
falls all around tonight for the 73
Championship Knicks
for Derrick Rose
what's up with three you know he's
talked about
his situation he said what he's been
asked about perhaps taking the buy out
going somewhere to have an opportunity
to win a title he said I'm still in the
league of 35. that's like winning a
championship all right he's a very
pragmatic guy
only Nick fans with that missed shot
would be going oh like it was a game
with a shot
there's McBride back out grows from
three
again the crowd moves and grows